well
i don't know how to break this to you
but
you're not getting any younger
i don't know whoever invented that term
but it's kind of a weird comment uh
of course we all know we're all aging
but how can we extend
our life in fact that's one of my goals
is to help people live longer
and definitely a more quality of life
now is there a really good test to
determine how long you're going to live
can you really tell by how many wrinkles
a person has i mean the person who has
the record for longevity is they live to
122 years that's pretty long time
there
probably were people that lived longer
than that but it wasn't really well
documented i remember in practice
i would do a lot of um seminars
outside my office in different
governmental agencies
and uh one lady wanted me to come to
where she was living in an assisted
living
home and they had um you know different
age ranges from i guess 60 uh up to
maybe 90. and i remember when i was in
the room giving this presentation i
asked the age of everyone in that room
and i was shocked to find out there were
people living there in their 60s that
were literally
in wheelchairs like 63 65 years old i
was like wow incredible i'm going on 58
years old
and i'm actually a grandfather which is
just like a bizarre concept because i
don't look at myself as being old
i mean i remember being young and
looking at my grandparents when they
were in 50s thinking wow they're so old
so anyway i think your 60s are the new
40s okay that's just my viewpoint but
you can't really tell how long someone's
going to live based on
the wrinkles that they have or
how gray their hair is or how much
they've lost your hearing or
how much they lost their sight
or if they lost their cognitive function
some people that have dementia could
live for a very long time
now calcification is a good predictor of
mortality if you have calcification in
your arteries but as people age they
become calcified their joints become
calcified their tissues become stiff
that's
calcium building up
also as we age we get shorter we lose
height
our spine starts to shrink
all right next one is bone loss which
relates to being shorter and also
as we age we tend to fall more than we
should but
there's another indication
for longevity that i want to talk about
and that is loss of muscle
both in muscle mass and strength as we
age we lose our muscle and that is a
very strong association between
loss of muscle strength
and your mortality of aging
not necessarily the mass of the muscle
how big the muscle is but the strength
of your muscle because as we age we get
atrophy right we have a loss of muscle
and the term for that is called
sarcopenia
and the number one muscle that's
affected first
is the anterior thigh the quadricep okay
this is why you see especially after
menopause and more in women because they
have more estrogen you'll see a lot of
weakness in that quadricep muscle you'll
see
it looks like cellulite but it's really
atrophy which is a combination of fat
but there's a lot of muscle loss as well
so one test they use to determine
sarcopenia other than a cat scan or mri
which is the gold standard is a
sit-to-sand time test or a chair stand
test cst test so this test right here
can indirectly give you a clue on kind
of how much sarcopenia you have and
indirectly that can be related to how
long you live of course there's other
factors but this can be a really good
clue so i want to do an experiment right
now okay i want you
just to stand up right now if you're
sitting just stand up of course you're
probably not standing up watching your
computer but stand up unless you're on
your cell phone and comment down below
if there's difficulty in standing up
does it take you a long time can you
stand up very fast you know probably
even a better test would be to
sit on the floor and get up in a
standing position if you have sarcopenia
boy you're going to have to roll over
and rock up and you're going to have to
push yourself up it's going to take a
long time to get up versus jumping up
quickly which means
you can rule out this condition really
fast there's another really good test
okay there's so there's two tests i'm
going to recommend one is a hand grip
strength test okay you can use one of
those grip strength devices
and if you're a male and
cannot
grip strength 66 pounds or
30 kilograms of grip strength then
potentially there's a problem and you
could have this condition
and if you're female it would be 44
pounds or 20 kilograms of grip strength
so these are two really good
home tests to just to see where you're
at on the scale of things now let's just
talk about what we can do
for longevity
okay what can we do to increase
um our length of life
and make sure it's quality and also what
can we do for
sarcopenia a lot of people have this
condition one of the biggest symptoms of
a low vitamin d deficiency is muscle
weakness okay so vitamin d
is essential for making sure that your
muscles
stay strong especially if you have
sarcopenia so the first thing that i
would highly recommend is start taking
vitamin d for your muscle strength it
just so happens vitamin d is also
associated with longevity because
vitamin d is intimately involved with
your immune system with inflammation
it's it has anti-cancer properties it's
great for the heart
it's good for autoimmune diseases it's
involved with so many different things
it's actually i think 19 000 genes that
it can affect so vitamin d is slightly
important okay number two resistance
training very very important if you can
maintain a routine exercise program okay
where you're doing resistance type
exercise that would be very therapeutic
to your longevity versus not doing
exercise or doing it inconsistently now
i like to switch up my exercises i'll do
all sorts of different exercises like
i'm still doing my sled up a hill
backwards i'm pulling i did a video with
a guy by the name of ben patrick which
is the knees over toes guy
it was a really good interview which
involves walking backwards and pulling
things backwards so i'm still doing that
exercise but lately i'm also doing
pilates i really like pilates works the
whole body and a new type of exercise
which is actually quite fascinating it's
it's a little different it's called
gyrotonics
i'll put a link down below but it's a
fascinating
uh exercise program that involves
strengthening
motions okay and like a 3d not like a
flexion extension type exercise but
you're
exercising your entire body in different
ranges of motion so you'll have to just
see it to understand it you have to go
to a gym that has these machines it's
pretty awesome all right number three
this is very important not just for
sarcopenia but for longevity
nutrient-dense foods i'll just give you
one little example let's say for example
you are deficient in folic acid okay or
folate right
well
that alone can create
the same damage
as radiation okay to your dna so in
other words if you're deficient in
folate
your dna
uh become damaged and they can't repair
that alone will shorten your life
there's some
fascinating research that's just one
nutrient okay number four fasting
this will extend your life definitely
but let's say for example you're getting
older and you have sarcopenia and
maybe you just do one meal a day right
because you might not be in a situation
you can fast five days especially if
your muscles are weak um not a good idea
but
one meal a day very smart
but fasting increases growth hormone it
increases autophagy which is the
recycling of old damaged proteins it'll
definitely increase your life
okay number five keep your cortisol low
cortisol is very destructive
on your muscles okay especially your
legs and your butt muscle
if you haven't seen that video i'll put
that video down below but
cortisol is necessary in normal amounts
but not in high amounts if you have too
much cortisol boy that will just really
paralyze your immune system and shorten
your life
number six and i think
from my own viewpoint this is should be
number one okay state of mind if they've
done research on this
having a life that has meaning
is very vital for your longevity your
role happiness and unfortunately it's
not the majority there's not a lot of
people
that are doing what they really want to
do but i would venture to say that state
of mind is the number one factor for
longevity all right number seven
adequate and quality protein if we're
dealing with sarcopenia we're dealing
with having the raw material to replace
all your proteins not just muscle but
all the biochemical pathways
we need adequate protein and we
definitely need quality protein eggs are
at the top of the list okay and then if
we just talk about sarcopenia itself
there's a version of an amino acid
called leucine called h
m or b it's kind of a metabolite of
leucine that can help correct sarcopenia
i just want to add this to the mix
because if someone has sarcopenia this
is a good remedy
and there's a lot to learn about
longevity and so i think your next most
important video to watch would be on
this topic right here check it out
you